اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض وننصدم معكم ابرز
المستجدات وفي العناوين
الجيش الاوكراني يقصد تعزيزات الروسيه
اضافيه الى البحر الاسود وتحركات قتاليه ل
15 سفينه
مسؤول ايراني
تحت الرماد ويرجح الدلاعها من جديد
مقتل شاب برصاص مستوطن اسرائيلي في الضفه
لحكومه نتنياهو ضدها منفذ الهجمات
نقيب تونسي يدون باصواتهم في الدوري
الثاني من الانتخابات البرلمانيه ووسط
دعوات للمقاطعه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا افادت القوات الاخرانيه
انها رصد التعزيزات الروسيه اضافيه عبر
القرم الى البحر الاسود وتحركات قتاليه
لخمسه 10 سفينات هذا هو اعلى المستشار
الرئاسي الاوكراني
محادثات عاجله تجري بينك وخلفائها بشان
طلبات الحصول على صواريخ بعيده المدى وقال
مستشار الاوكراني اين طلب بلاده جاء
لتقليص تاثير السلاح الرئيسي لجيش الروسي
الى حد كبير واضحا ان قواته تحتاج الى
صواريخها تدمر مستودعات الروس كما لما حمد
ليا ان القوه القرانيه تريد قصف شبه جزيره
القرم حيث يوجد بها اكثر من 100 مستودع
مدفعيه بحسب وصفه قبل ذلك مشاهدينا اشد
الرئيس
اوكرانيا تريد السباق الهجمات الروسيه على
المناطق الحضريه الاخرانيه والمدنيين
بمزيد من القوه واوضح هذه المسك ان
اوكرانيا بحاجه الى صواريخها بعيده المدى
لحرمان روسيا من فرصه
في مكان بعيد عن خط المواجهه وتدمير المدن
الاوكرانيه حسب
قولهاب الروسي اذا تمكن من تزويد جيشنا
بقوه صاروخيه ذات صله حتى لا يشعر
الارهابيون بالافلات من العقاب تحتاج
اوكرانيا الى صواريخها بعيده المدى وذلك
لازاله هذا الخيار للغازات لتدمير المدن
الاوكرانيه باستخدام قاذفات صواريخ منتشره
بعيدا عن خط المواجهه
بدوره اعلن رئيس اللجنه العسكريه في حلف
الناتو ان الحلفه مستعد لمواجهه مباشره مع
روسيا واكد اوروبا ان اهداف موسكو
الاستراتيجيه تتجاوز حدود اوكرانيا وذلك
خلال لقاء صحفي وقال باور ان روسيا تنوي
العوده الى حدود الاتحاد السوفيتي مشيرا
الى انه ينبغي اعاده توجيه الانتاج
الصناعي لدوي حلف الاطلسي الى المجال
العسكري وان اعاده التسلق تعد اولويه هذا
هو كانت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه اعلنت
انها منفتحه على الحوار مع النيترو مشيره
الى ان على الغربي التخلي عن سياسته في
عسكره القاره في المقابل مشاهدينا وصف
نائبه وزير الخارجيه الروسيه سيرجيريا
تصريحات واشنطن بان شحنات دبابات ابرام
ليست صيدا وصفها بالانكار لامور واضحه الى
ان الولايات المتحده اتخذت هذه الخطوه من
اجل الصعيد الوضع داخل حلف الناتو واعتبر
خلال مقابله مع وكاله سبوت ان ارسال كتيبه
دبابات الى اوكرانيا خطوه مدمره للغايه من
جانب امريكا مضيفا انها محاوله لتنفيذ
سيناريو تصعيد واضح في اوكرانيا وخطوه من
اجل ترتيب نيته مره اخرى لحساب الولايات
المتحده
مشاهدينا من كياب ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا بك حذيفه ودعنا
نبدا من التطورات الميدانيه ماذا لديك
اليوم
24 ساعه الماضيه انخفضت وتيره القصف حتى
في جبهه القتال نفسها حيث اطلق الجيش
الروسي صاروخ واحد على طبعا النجم عن هذا
القصف لهذه المدينه بعد الجرح يعني حوالي
12 جريحا وقتيل واحد في منطقه قسطنطينه
ايضا نفذت القوات الروسيه اثناء الثنتين
وثلاثين ضربه جويه 65 ضربه جماعه الصواريخ
تتركز جهود القوات الروسيه في الدوريسك
تحديدا في ثلاثه اتجاهات في باخمه وفي
نوفمبر هذه الثلاثه محاور الاساسيه التي
تقوم بها القوات الروسيه بعمليات هجوم
ناشطه اما في زبروزه وليمان وكوبر
القوات الروسيه هناك تدافع والقوات
الاوكرانيه هي التي تهاجم هذا بخصوص جبهات
القتال بشكل عام ههه طيب حذيفه يعني مع
هذه الهجمات الروسيه التي اشرت اليها هناك
حديث اوكراني يتكرر كثير هذه الايام وهو
مع الغرب عن ضروره امتلاك صواريخ بعيده
المدى وبقاتلات ايضا هل كيف متفائله
باحداث اختراق في هذا الملف كما حدث ايضا
مع في ملف الدبابات
اؤكد بشكل واضح وصرحت في اكثر من مناسبه
واكثر من مره واكثر من مسؤول على راسهم
ووزير خارجته لمتر كوليبا الان الدوله
الاوكرانيه تضع عيونها الحصول على همم 16
وعلى الصواريخ بعيده المدى قال كوليبا
مباشره بعد الاعلان عن الموافقه بامداد
فيه الدبابات قال الان الملف الرئيسي
بالنسبه لوزاره الخارجيه هو المفاوضات
للحصول على اسلحه متقدمه طبعا يتحدث 16
تحديدا وعن همم الصواريخ بعيده المدراكين
متفائله جدا انها سوف تحدث اختراقها في
هذا الملف ميخائيل بودلال اننا الان ناخذ
همم مفاوضات نشطه جدا للوصول الى هذه
النتيجه
بالمقابل كيف تحاول ان توصل الرساله
للشركاء بشكل واضح انها لن تقوم به هجوم
داخل اراضي الاتحاد الروسي انها لن تتحدى
حدود 19 واحد وتسعين الحدود الدوليه
المعترف بها للدوله الاوكرانيه هي سوف
تقود هجوم مضاد لاستعاده السيطره على
اراضيها وبحديثك عن الحدود بلا روسيا تقول
ان اوكرانيا حشدت اكثر من 17 الف مقاتل
على حدودها هل
ما الذي يقلق اوكرانيا تحديدا في هذه
المنطقه هذه حذيفه
احمد هذه الحدود الشماليه هي الاقرب الى
عاصمه اوكرانيا كيف ساعتين او ثلاثه ساعات
على الاكثر يمكن لاي قوات ان تنتقل من
الحدود الى وسط العاصمه كيف هذه الحدود
التي دخلت منها القوات الروسيه وطبعا تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه انه كان معها بعد
القوات الفلل الروسيه ودخلت واستطاعت
الوصول الى تخون فيه وحصار مدينه كيف هذا
هو المقلق طبعا لذلك طبعا كنا الفريق
العربيه تعرف الحدود قبل فتره همم
الفتره قريبه جدا كله صدع الوضع الميداني
في الحدود الروسيه هنالك تجهيزات كبيره
جدا من الجيش الاخراني هندسيه قام
بانشائها لتحصين هذه الحدود التحصيلات
تبدا من كيف حتى الحدود الشماليه وقائد
القوات المدافعه كيف يقول ان همم جبهه
الدفاع في الحدود مع فلسطين
عربيه حذيفه
مشاهدينا اعلن رئيس لجنه الحدود بلا روسيه
ان الوضع الحدود مع اوكرانيا لا يزال
متوترا وشرا الى حشد قواتك كما ذكرنا قبل
قليل نحو 17 الف عسكريين على الحدود
وقالوا ان الجنود اوكرانيين ليسوا حرس
حدود فقط وانما وحدات عسكريه اخرى كما
اوضح رئيس لجنه الحدود البيلاروسيه انهم
مندذ الى عمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا وصل
حوالي ثمانيه الف شخص من الارض الاوكرانيه
الى بلاده وان الجانب الاوكرانيه لا يسمح
الاخرانيين بدخول الاراضي بلا روسيه رغم
ان ماسك مستعده لاستقبالهم
في ايران اعترف عضو مجلس تشخيص مصلحه
النظام الايراني محمد رضا بهنر ان الفساده
وانعدام الكفاءه وعدم الاستماع بصوت الشعب
اصبحت حقائق عن النظام الحالي وسلطاته
محذرا من خطوره عدم حل هذه القضايا كونها
ستؤدي الى استمرار الاحتجاجات المتواصله
في البلاد وذلك خلافا لما يعتقده
المسؤولون حسب قوله واضاف ان هذه
الاحتجاجات تشبه نارا تحت الرماد وستزيد
من اشتعال الاوضاع في ايران وحول الهجمات
التي استهدفت مواقع عسكريه ايرانيه
بالطائره المسيره اكد لحرس الثوري
الايراني وقوع الهجوم على موقع عسكري في
اصفهان وزاره الدفاع الايراني مشاهدينا
قالت ان الدفاعات الجويه تصدت لواحده من
هذه الطائرات المسيره فيما سقطت طائرتان
في فخاخ دفاعيا هذا وكان عاشقون ايرانيون
اكدوا استماع عدويه فجرات عده استهدفت
مصنع للذخيره في اصفهان فيما تناقلت مواقع
ايرانيه نابا انفجارات اخرى استهدفت بواقع
حمدان وكره وقاعده نوجا وبتوازي تحدثت
مصادر اعلاميه اسرائيليه عن عمليه في
الداخل الايراني وربطت بين توقيتها وزياره
رئيس الاستخبارات الامريكيه المركزيه في
اي اي الى تل ابيب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مقاطع فيديو لانفجارات في العاصمه
الايرانيه طيران
يدور اشتباك المسلح بين الاكراد والقوات
الحكوميه في مدينه الجوانب بمحافظه كرماشه
الكرديه غربيه ايران ووفقا لتقارير
ميدانيه تعرض مركز الشرطه رقم 11 في هذه
المدينه لاطلاق نار وتفيد بعض المعلومات
بمقتل احد افراد قوه الحكوميه في هذا
الاجتماع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من دبي الصحفيه
الايراني مسعود الفتح معنا
وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه على غير ماجره
العاده قد سعرات الاعتراف بهذا الهجوم
لماذا في تقديرك
تحياتي لك وللمشاه الكرام طبعا خلافا
للعاده اعلنت بسرعه وزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه لان التجارب السابقه في كتمان
الاحداث اعطت نتائج عكسيه حيث اضطر
المسؤولون الايرانيون ان ياتوا
ويعترفوا باحداث
وقعت كما ان شده الانفجار كانت الى درجه
واضحه وفي منطقه متلاصقه بالمدينه لا يمكن
كتمانه اكثر من ذلك والصور انتشرت على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كالنار في الهشيم
هذا دفع النظام بان يحترف بسرعه ويصدر
بيان
ليقدم ايضاحات حول الحادث طبعا
حجه
من من خطر هذا الانفجار وقالت ان الاطار
اتصلت فقط على اسطح المباني هل يمكن
التعوي او الاعتماد على بقيه هذا البيان
لو كان صحيحا او خطا
بيعتقاد هذا ليس مهما بقدر ما يهمنا
الرساله التي يمكن ارسالها من خلال هذا
الهجوم لو قبلنا جدلا بروايه ايه وزاره
الدفاع الايرانيه بان الهجوم كان فاشل
ولكن ان تصل المسيرات الى احدى اهم المدن
الايرانيه التي تضم كثير من المنشات
النوويه والعسكريه والصناعيه الايرانيه
هذا هو السؤال المهم كيف وصلت هذه
المسيرات في مدينه تقع في وسط ايران هي
ليست من منطقه حدوديه بل بالضبط في وسط
ايران هنا همم الامر مهم جدا من الناحيه
العسكريه بان من يريد استهداف المنشات
الايرانيه
بامكانه ان يصل اليها حتى لو كانت في قلب
البلد وفي مركز البلد
الرئيس الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
الى تل ابيب في هذا التوقيت هل له اي
دلاله معينه
[موسيقى]
وهذا الصراع له علاقه
بمحاوله
النفوذ الاقليمي في المنطقه ولا يتعلق
بقضايا اخرى لا يتعلق بقضيه فلسطين لا
يتعلق بقضايا من هذا القبيل المساله
المساله صراع بين جهتين جهه تريد ان تبسط
نفوذها وجهه اخرى متخوفه من هذا من هذا
الامر لدى همم اسرائيل لها دخل في كثير من
الاحداث في داخل ايران في الهجوم الذي تم
في سنه
2011 على اهم منشاه
صاروخيه ايرانيه وقتل 16 ضابط ايراني
اسرائيل كانت المتهمه الهجوم الذي تم فيه
2021 على
قاعده مسيراتيه لايران شاء تم تدمير
المسيرات الايراني اسرائيل لها دخل وايضا
الهجمات التي تعرضت لها المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه بما في ذلك منشات نابلس التي هي
ايضا تقع في محافظه اسوان
الصحفيه المختص في الشيء الايراني
على صنع اسلحه نوويه وقال جرسي ان ايران
لديها ما يكفي من اليورانيوم على التخصيب
لصنع عده اسلحه النوويه
اكد في وقت سابق على ضروره التوخي الحذر
الشديد حول برنامج
الفاصل
وسط حراك امريكي فلسطيني
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في القدس
الشرقيه التوتر يتصاعد بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين حيث افادت وكاله الانباء
الفلسطينيه عن مقتل شاب فلسطيني في رصاص
الجيش الاسرائيلي شرق بلده قلقيليه في
الضفه الغربيه وحسب مصادر امنيه فان كرم
علي سلمان البالغي 18 عاما من بلده قوسين
غربيه نابلس برصاص قرب مسلطنه كادومي
الهجمات الاخيره في القدس وقال مجلس
الوزراء الامنيه
من حقوق معينه وفي اجتماع طارق
ومن يدعمهم يدفعون الثمن على حد وصفهه
وبحسب البيان الذي اصدره المجلس فانه سيتم
الغائه الحق في الضمان الاجتماعي
كما اشار الى انه سيتم مناقشته مشروع
قانون يهدف الى السحب بطاقات الهويه
الاسرائيليه
هذه العائله متابعه
طلاقا من الفهم بان لا قدره تقريبا
لاسرائيل على مواجهه العمليات الفرديه غير
المنظمه ولا عنواننا للرد عليها حاول
نتنياهو عندما تلا اهم قرارات الحكومه
الامنيه المصغره ان يطفي بعدا دراما تكيا
على القرارات لاحتواء غضب الشارع اليمني
ربما
ودقيقه من يحاول المسافه بين سنستهدفه
ونستهدف كل من يساعده لقد اجرينا اعتقالات
في صفوف دعميه الارهاب والمحرضين وننشر
ونعزز القوه على الجبهات المختلفه
تسهيل ترخيص حمل السلاح للاسرائيليين وسد
او هدموا منازل عائلات منفذين عمليات
ومحاوله تشريع قانون يتيح ابعاد عائلات
المنفذين من القدس والداخل الى جانب تعزيز
الاجراءات القبليه كانت ابرز ما توافقت
عليه الحكومه الامنيه
بشكل كبير لذلك يتوقع ان يكون الخطوات
تصعيديه عقوبات جماعيه وهذا سيغذي يعني
حاله احتفال موجوده والعمليات وربما نحن
امام موجه قد تمتد واذا امتدت ربما يعني
تكود الى وضع همم تفلت فيه الامور وتفقد
فيه السيطره بشكل كامل في اسرائيل ليقرون
بان العمليات الفرديه كالتي جرت في
مستوطنه في القدس الشرقيه المحتله وقتل
فيها سبعه مستوطنين او تلك التي نفذها فتن
في سلوان ضد مستوطنين الى جانب عمليات
اطلاق النار في الضفه
استمر في اطار التصعيد القائم والمتفائم
وفيما حاولت الحكومه استغلالها للتركيز
على الملف الامني وحرف الانظار عن الازمه
الداخليه بسبب الحرب على النظام القضائي
اصر عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين على
التظاهر في تل ابيب حيث اجبر الحكومه على
تغيير موقع الاجتماع وفي مدن اخرى ايضا
زياد حلب العربيه القدس الغربيه
بصوت اعمق على طبيعه القرارات الاسرائيليه
المتحده اساء هذه التوترات بين فلسطين
والاسرائيليين وما رشح عن مشادات كلامي
ايضا حدث بين قاده الجيش والحكومه
الاسرائيليه همم اثناء اجتماع يتوفرت
معلومات حول ذلك
نعم احمد يعني حتى منذ صباح اليوم بدا
الجيش الاسرائيلي بتنفيذ هذه القرارات
التي تحدثت ايضا عنها هي قرارات مجلس
الوزاري الامني المصغر للشؤون الامنيه
والسياسيه الكبنت ويعني كان من ابرزها هو
اغلاق وتمهيدا ايضا لهدم بعض بيوت منفدي
او منازل منفديه العمليات ومنذ صباح اليوم
قامت الشرطه الاسرائيليه باغلاق منزل منفذ
عمليه النبي يعقوب ايضا في الطور في القدس
وايضا قبل قليل كانت القوات الاسرائيليه
تتجه الى الى حي سلوان حيث نفذ او حيث نفذ
محمد عليوات عفوا وهو طفل ثلاثه عشر عاما
قام بتنفيذ هذه العمليه في سلوان وايضا
يعني اتجه له اغلاق منزله في حي سلوان
المتواجد في القدس الشرقيه المحتله يعني
هناك عده همم عده قرارات يعني قام همم
للمجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر كان من ابرز
هيا تعزيز القوات الاسرائيليه في الضفه
وايضا في القدس واضافه الى ذلك هو يعني
موافقه على اعطاء المزيد من الاسلحه
للمستوطنين لحمايه انفسهم حسب ما اتقول
الشرطه الاسرائيليه ولكن يعني ربما هذه
الاوضاع ايضا سوف تصاعب الوضع فراينا يعني
المستوطنين كان هناك استنفار كبير في
شوارع القدس حيث خرج عشرات المستوطنين
يعني غاضبين وهم يهتفون على الموت العرب
والموت الفلسطينيين في الشوارع القدس ليله
امس يعني وايضا حاولوا الهجوم على مركبات
فلسطينيه في القدس الشرقيه المحتله في ظل
تواجد عدد ايضا من الشرطه همم حول المنطقه
ولكن الشرطه الاسرائيليه لم تتدخل في يعني
نحن نرى وتوترات كبيره في ظل قرارات
الحكومه ال- ال- الاسرائيليه الجميله يعني
ربما هذه ايضا القرارات لن تمنع منفذي
العمليات الفرديه من تنفيذ عمليات اخرى
هو عن هذا قرارات ايضا يعني هل جميع هذه
القرارات قابله للتنفيذ ام انها قد تصدي
بعقبات اجرائيه وقانونيه تعقد من تنفيذها
في المستقبل لان حتى هناك مثلا هناك تفاوت
في التعاطي مع عائلات المنفذين لهذه
الهجمات ومساكينهم او منازلهم باختلاف
المناطق في القدس الغربيه ليس كذلك
السابق ايضا قد صرح صباح اليوم وقال بان
يعني الحكومه اليمنيه الفعليه ان هي عاجزه
الان في التعامل مع هذه العمليات الفرديه
وقال يعني عندما يكون هناك يعني اشخاص
ينتمون الى فصائل معينه اسرائيل لديها
فعليا عنوان ترجع اليه هو يعني ربما ترد
هذا ال- ال- هذه العمليه
الانتقام ربما من هذه الفصائل او هذا
العنوان ولكن اليوم اسرائيل موجوده همم في
همم يعني في منطقه اللي هي صعبه صعبه جدا
لا يوجد هناك عنوان سواء العائلات وهي
تحاول الان يعني فرض عقوبات كبيره على هذه
العائلات مثل يعني اغلاق وهدم هذه المنازل
وايضا حرمان عائلات هذه الفلسطينيين من
التامين الوطني وهو الخدمات مثلا الخدمات
الصحه التي تقدمها ايضا الشرطه همم
الحكومه الاسرائيليه للفلسطينيين
شكرا لك من القدس كنت معنا ممارسه العربيه
لا ناكل غاص تحياتي لان على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
يبدا وزير الخارجيه الامريكان جوله في
الشرق الاوسط من العاصمه المصريه القاهره
تشمل ايضا زياره لاسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه وخلال زيارته للقاهره يلتقي
المسؤول الامريكي نظيره المصري سامح شكري
كما يجري مباحثات مع الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي ومسؤولينا مصريين الوزير
الامريكي مشاهدينا سيبحث في القاهره تعزيز
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين وتعزيز
فرص السلام والامن في المنطقه لما في ذلك
الدعم المشترك للانتخابات في ليبيا الى
جانبي دعم لعمليه السياسيه الجاريه في
السودان ويحمل الوزير بنك معه في دولته
الاقليميه ملف التصعيد الاخير في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه اذا تحاول واشنطن وقفه سعيد
هذا وقال وزير خارج امريكانا عبر حسابه في
تويتر ان زيارته للمنطقه ستشمل كل من مصر
واسرائيل والضفه الغربيه واعتبر ان رحلته
الرابعه تؤكد التزام بلاده بتعميق
العلاقات بين الشعوب وتعديل حقوق الانسان
وتقويه الامن الاقليميه
مشاهدينا من القاهره يضم الينا مراسله
العربيه الثامنه وصلت اهلا بك تامر الى
مساء متى سيصل لوزير الخارج الامريكي
القاهره واضاءه اخرى وعمق على الملفات
التي ستناقش في اجده هذه الزياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي يتوقع ان يصل خلال
ساعتين او اقل من ذلك ويبدا زيارته
للقاهره يبدا زيارته القارئ همم ربما
التركيز سيكون في الغد عندما يلتقي الرئيس
عبد الفتاح السيسي والذي بالمناسبه يتواجد
الان همم في اول زياره منا وقال الرئيس
المصري الى ارمينيا فبالتالي لقاء بلينكن
والسيسي سيتم غدا همم يليه لقاء مع وزير
الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري ومؤتمر همم
صحفي همم هذا اللقاء همم فبالتالي الوصول
اليوم همم ربما سوف يكون للاعداد للزياره
ومناقشه الملفات مع اعضاء السفاره
الامريكيه هنا في القاهره والبعث المصاحبه
لبنكن همم بطبيعه الحال عدد من الملفات
الذي اشارت اليها وخاصه دعم جهود الوساطه
الامميه ال- ال- للمضيق قدما في العمليه
الانتخابيه في ليبيا وكذلك استعاده الدوله
همم في السودان او يعني بقياده مدنيه في
السودان طبقا لاتفاق الايطالي اذا نظرنا
مثلا الى التصعيد الاخير الذي يحدث في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه فلا شك ان هذا سوف
يحتل اجانب اوسع من المناقشات المتعلقه
بالقضايا الاقليميه والدوليه التي سوف
يناقشها همم الوزير مع الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي وخاصه مع وجود جهود مصريه للوساطه
من اجل التهدئه كذلك همم اشارت الخارجيه
الامريكيه في بيان صباح اليوم او ما يمكن
ان يطلق عليه بوثيقه حقائق كما تسميها
الخارجيه الامريكيه انه سوف يكون ايضا همم
حوار او يجرح حول الشان الايراني كذلك
وايضا هناك عدد من الموضوعات المتعلقه
بمكافحه الارهاب والارتجار بالبشر وغيرها
من الموضوعات ايضا المتعلقه بالحريات
وحقوق الانسان وغيرها كما اشار البيان
اوكي هنا اودوا الاشاره مثلا الى عدد من
المحللين المصريين الذين تحدثوا عن ان
ازدواجيه المعايير الامريكيه فيما يتعلق
بالتسعيط في الاراضي الفلسطينيه همم خاصه
عندما يقارنون همم تصريحات الخارجيه
الامريكيه باجتياح جنين مقابل الاعتداء
على الكنيسه اليهودي ربما صلت الضوء على
ذلك الكاتب عبد الله عبد السلام الكاتب في
جريده الاهرام وهي جريده مملوكه للدوله
تحدث فيها عن ان غالبا الاداره الامريكيه
ليس لديها الحلول الجذريه وانما تاتي الى
هنا لكي تتحدث حول ايران بالتحديد سبق في
ذلك ويليام برنس وسبق في ذلك مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي في زياره كذلك للملتقى
عموما موضوع سد النهضه ايضا من الموضوعات
التي جاء ذكرها في همم الوثيقه الامريكيه
همم
وبالتالي بعد تغيير ثلاثه مبعوثين الى
القرن الافريقي في بحر سنه او يزيد تقريبا
همم ثالث من بعده سعد رفيده واخيرا الاول
امضي اقل من عام الثاني امضت ثلاثه اشهر
وثالث لم تظهر له كرامات بحسب المحللين
المصريين في هذا الشعب فطبعا هذا من
الموضوعات التي يمكن ان تكون يعني على
الساحه او على
تفاصيل هذه الزياره شكرا لك من القاهره
كنت معنا مراسل العربيه
كسرين الدار
مولعين سياره دار ام نجم
وقعت المؤسسه الوطنيه
لتراوح بين 750 و 800 مليونير قدم مكعب
يوميا لفتره 25 عاما توقيع الاتفاق جاء
اثناء زياره رئيس الوزراء الايطاليه الى
طرابلس منير والتفاصيل
زياره رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه الى طرابلس
التي رافقها فيها وزير الداخليه والخارجيه
ومدير عام شركه لم تكن زياره عاديه
[موسيقى]
اتفاقيات مع حكومه الوحده الوطنيه لمجال
الامن والمكافحه الهجره ولكن الاتفاق
الابرز كان بين مؤسسه النفط وشركه والذي
اثار
الحقول الملك اليوم للغاز حتى يتناقص
ممكن بعد ثلاثه اربع سنوات بتقدي في
التنقل لا بد ان نحافظ
ونزيد كميه الغاز المنتجه بشكل غطي حتى
احتياجات الشارع اللي يبيعون شان الليبي
ولا بالنا نحن بنصدر الضغط
100% المؤسسه الوطنيه
داخل البحر الابيض المتوسط
وباحتياطيه سته هجونات
وبعدين التركيبين البحريين
تم استكشافهم في السبعينات
وتم الاعلان التجاري عنهن في 2013 وهذا
الموضوع
سيعود بالنفع على
الاقتصاد الليبي سواء كان في شكل عوائد
تصل الى 18 مليار دولار او كان ايضا
توفير الغاز اللي محطه الكهرباء ولتصدير
ايضا الاتفاقيه التي عززت المكانه الرفيعه
للشركه الايطاليه في السوق الليبي اعادت
من جديد الانقسام السياسي بين الاجسام
المسيطره على المشهد على الانقسام لابد ان
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه تعرف ابعاده جيدا
لكننا تحولات الكبيره في سوق الطاقه في
العالم تتجاوز بعض العقبات احيانا على
الرغم من طبيعه الاتفاقيه النفطيه الموقعه
بين طرابلس وروما ولكنها تحمل في طيتها
العديده من الرسائل السياسيه خصوصا في ظل
المنافسه الاوروبيه على النفط والغاز في
ليبيا منير الاشهب طرابلس العربيه
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
رفع نسبه المشاركه يطغى على الدوره
الثانيه بانتخابات برلمان تونس اليوم
الجيش الاوكراني يرفض تعزيزات الروسيه
اضافيه الى البحر الاسود وتحركات قتاليه ل
15 سفينات
مسؤول ايراني
بالنار تحت الرماد ويرجحون ذراعها من جديد
مقتل شاب برصاص مستوطن اسرائيلي في الضفه
واجراءات لحكومه نتنياهو ضد عائلات منفذ
الهجمات
في الدور الثاني من الانتخابات البرلمانيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد انطلقت في تونس
اليوم الدوره الثانيه من الانتخابات
التشريعيه لاختيار اعضاء البرلمان ويتنافس
في هذه الدوره نحو 262 مرشحا على مئه
واحدث البرلمان الجديد من اصل
161 في انتخابات تمثل مرحله الاخيره من
خريطه طريق وضعها رئيس تونسي
اقتصاديه تلقي بظلالها على المشهد السياسي
وكان الرئيس سعيد جمد اعمال البرلمان
التونسي ثم قام بحليله لاحقا ثم طرح
دستورا جديدا للاستفتاء العام الماضي
مشاهدينا من تونس انضم الينا مراسل
العربيه وليد عبد الله اهلا بك ووليد وهل
فتحت مراكز الاقتراع ابوابها وكيف هي
الاجواء
مرحبا احمد نحن الان في احد مراكز
الاقتراع وهذا المركز بالصدفه يعني تقريب
متاخر لاصوار البرلمان خلف هذا المركز
تماما يوجد البرلمان الجديد الذي من الموز
على اقصى تقدير ان تنطلق اعماله بدايه شهر
مارس اذار العمليه انطلاقات منذ الساعه
الثامنه صباحا بالتوقيت
المحلي في
131 دائره انتخابيه يتنافس فيها 200 و 262
مرشح مرشحا عفوا بينهم 34 امراه
الفوز بمتبقى من مقاعد البرلمان ال 100
وال 131 على اعتبار ان 23 دائره انتخابيه
حسمت فيها الامور العمليه وفقا ما لحظناه
على الاقل في عدد من مراكز الاقتراح تمت
بثلاثه بشكل عظيم بتامين من قوات الجيش
والامن وطني نسبه الاقبال تبدو الى حدود
هذه اللحظه محتشمه على اعتبار انها ساعات
الاولى واليوم الاحد هو يوم عطله نفيات
تونس ان نطق الرسمي باسم هيئه الانتخابات
اكد للعربيه منذ قليل ان كل مراكز
الاقتراع في مختلف الدوائر الانتخابيه
وحتى تلك المناطق الحدوديه والداخليه فتحت
ابوابها بشكل عدي وفي نفس التوقيت ولم يتم
تسجيل اي تاخير على كل لو همم لدينا اقل
من وقت هذه هي الاجواء هنا في هذا المركز
في الدائره الانتخابيه بارده بقربه همم
مركز او قرب مقر البرلمان الحركه تبدو اقل
من العاديه لاحظنا منذ فتح مارك هذا
المركز همم
يبدو اقل من المتوسط للفئه العمريه
المتقدمه في السن من النساء والرجال
الشباب لما
حظو اقبالا من قبل الفئات الشبابيه
العموريه همم على هذا المركز وهو الامر
المتوقع خاصه وان الفئات الشبابيه تقبل
اكثر عند تقدم ساعات الاقتراع التي من
المفترض ان تدوم 10 ساعات وان تغلق كل
مراكز الاقتراع على الساعه السادسه
الانتخابات
في هذه الدوره وتحفيزا الناخبين اللي هو
دفعهم للمشاركه بشكل اوسع هل استفادت
الهيئه من التجربه السابقه التي كانت فيها
المشاركه ضعيفه جدا لان هناك حديث عن
برامج همم
توعويه كبيره كانت في التلفزيون عن رسائل
همم في الهواتف ايضا لتحفيظ المشاركين في
هذه الانتخابات
وهو كذلك بالفعل ربما الهيئه رغم
الانتقادات المواجهه لها فيما يتعلق
باداره العمليه من حيث الناحيه اللوجستيه
وخاصه لاتصاليه فيما يتعلق بالدور الاول
للاستحقاق التشريعي على اعتبار تغييره
القانون الانتخابي يبدو ان الهيئه حاول
تفادي هذه الاخطاء من خلال تغيير سياستها
الاتصاليه سواء على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او بالتواصل مع المرشحين للدوره
الثانيه للانتخابات التشريعيه وعقد لقاءات
معهم في مختلف الدوائر الانتخابيه وايضا
التعريف بهم على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وايضا على القنوات التلفزيه العموميه
والخاصه وعقد مناظرات والايضا الاتصال
عبر الارساليات القصيره او ايضا توجيه
البيانات لوسائل الاعلام او ايضا على
موقعها الرسميه على مواقع التواصل همم
حاولت اقصى ما يمكن ان تحفز الناخبين
قرابه الثمانيه ملايين ناخم على توجه الى
صناديق الاقتراع والتوضيح كيفيه سير
العمليه الانتخابيه خاصه وان الاقماع في
الدور الاول كان محتشما الهيئه تتوقع بعد
الحمله الانتخابيه ان تكون نسب الاقبال
بين 20
و30% همم
تفاصيل هذا اليوم الطويل شكرا لك من تونس
كنت معنا مراسل العربيه
سباق الى البيت الابيض ينطلق مبكرا حيث
بدا الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
رحلته الى البيت الابيض بشكل رسمي من خلال
حمله الانتخابيه في ولايتي لوهامشر
كثير من المراقبين ان لولايه نفوذا كبيرا
بحصول المرشحين الفائزين في انتخاباتها
الرئاسيه التمهيديه على تزكيات حزبهم لخوض
الانتخابات الرئاسيه العامه
بهذه الاجواء الحماسيه تجمع انصار الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب امام مبنى
مقر ولايه سلط كارولينا احدى ولايات
التصويت المبكر في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التمهيديه
مئات الجمهوريين قدموا من مختلف انحاء
الولايه المهمه في الانتخابات التمهيديه
الى عاصمتها كولومبيا لدعم ترامب وتعزيزي
حظوظه في الترشح رغم ان استطلاعات للراي
تظهر عدد من الجمهوريين في الولايه يرغبون
في ترشح شخص اخر لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسي
حلوان مراد
[موسيقى]
الذين فازوا بالانتخابات التمهيديه في
ولايه ساوث كارولينا حصلوا على تزكيه
حزبهم لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه لهذا ينظر
الى هذه الولايه كبوصله في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه
ترامب الذي كان محاط بابرز مؤيديه في ساوث
كارولينا ومنهم السيناتور عن الولايه
لينزي غرام والحاكم هنري ماك ماستر لم
يغير من نمره خطابه المعتاده
اون تايوان
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه السابقه لدى الامم المتحده
حسين الطاوضه من ولايه ساوث كارولينا
العربيه
من يخلف الزعيم سؤال طرحته صحيفه التايمز
البريطانيه وكشفت ان زعيم كوريا
حسب امره هويه من سيخلفه بعد رحيله ليختار
طفلته البالغه من عمري 10 سنوات
[موسيقى]
الامور في البلاد الطفله المحبوبه لزعيم
كوريا
ستكون خليفه
تايمز البريطانيه
وبعد هذا الامر واضحا بعد ان كشف كم
النقابه عن ابنته البالغه من العمر عشره
اعوام مخالفه بذلك تقاليد الحكم المتعارف
عليها ليربط الاخلاص له بالولاء لطفلته
لانه ينوي تعزيز فكره انها هي من ستخلفه
تقول صحيفه البريطانيه
ابعد من ذلك ظهور طفلتي كم يهدف الى نزع
فتيل التنافس الحاد بين الامراتين الاكثر
اهميه في حياته وهما زوجته وشقيقته
الطموحه كم يوم جونغ لانه في حاله رحيل كم
من دون ان يكون لديه خليفه معروفه فان ذلك
سيؤدي الى فراغ في السلطه وبالتالي فان
الصراع سيحتدم بين الارمله والشقيقه
فشقيقه كم قويه جدا وعدوانيه وطموحه
وزوجته كم غير راضيه عنها ولاجل ذلك اخرج
الزعيم الكري ابنته الى العلم لتفادي
الصراع وتدهور البلاد في حال وفاته ولكن
حتى الساعه تعد شقيقه زعيم البالغه من
العمر 35 عاما اقوى امراه في البلاد لانها
الاقرب اليه من مساعديه والمتحدثه باسمه
في ما يتعلق بالعلاقات مع كوريا الجنوبيه
مشاهدينا في الرقاء تسع نطاق مشاركه
المراه في الحياه العامه بعد خمس سنوات
على تحرير المدينه من داعش الذي جرد
المراه من حقوقها الاساسيه في هذا التقرير
يرصد مراسل العربيه زيم الجماعه عكاشه
القطاعات والمجالات التي بدات المراه
تتبوء فيها اعلى المناصب نتبعه
م ولا تطوحوا بنخله الاسير ابتعدوا عني
لاكتب نصي الاخير على ضوء شمعه ذهب الى
طالما اشتكت من صخب المصابيح
حمزاوي اليوم اشعارها وتقف لتشرح بفخر قصه
لوحتها الوحيده التي نجت من داعش
كانت هذه اللوحه احدى اللوحات التي حافظت
على نفسها ونجت من ارهاب داعش من
تمزيقها اييه هي المراه
التي ناضلت ضد الارهاب وارادت ان تخرج
بالوانها الزاهيه
الى جانب الفني والشعر والرسم افتتحت
حمزاوي عملها الخاص كما انها ترشد مع
المنظمات المدنيه والاحزاب المحليه
لتفعيل دور المراه
تشارك قصتها نسوه اخريات اقتحممنا مجالات
الدفاع وتعملنا اليوم كشرطيات مرور او
عناصر امن الى جانب العمل السياسي اذ
اصبحت المراه تتراس اليوم اكبر الاحزاب
السياسيه في المدينه
نلاحظ تواجد مميز وملحوظ للمراه في كافه
مجالات وميادين والحياه في الرقه سواء
الاداريه سواء العسكريه سواء الاقتصاديه
سواء سياسيه وحتى في منظمات المجتمع
المدني
ورغم الخطوات الكبيره التي خططها المراه
في الرقه الا ان قيودا كثيره لا تزالوا
تشكل عقبه اساسيه امام توسيع مشاركتها في
الحياه العامه من الرقه جمع كاش العربيه
اعلانات الامانه العامه لمجلس التعاون
لدول الخليج العربيه
2023 خلفا لنايف الحجر الذي رحب بتعيين
جاسم البداوي يذكر ان البداوي الكويت في
عدد من المؤتمراته وعامله في بعثات الكويت
الدلوماسيه في اوقات سابقه بكل من
الولايات المتحده والامم المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي وبلجيكا وكوريا كذلك
تسببت موجه البرد التي تشهدها افغانستان
منذ حوالي 20 يوما بوفاه ما لا يقل عن 266
شخصا حيث تبنى الدرجات الحراره الى ثلاثه
وثلاثين درجه تحت الصفر في بعض مناطق
البلاد
الشتاء الاكثر عنفا في افغانستان يرفع
حصيله ضحاياه الى
166 قتيلا بسبب البرد درجه الحراره بلغ
الثلاثا و30 تحت الصفر مع تراجع المساعدات
الانسانيه
في عمل المنظمات الانسانيه
بسبب قرارات طالبان ضد عمل المراه
من موجه البرد القاسيه التي ضربت
افغانستان الى هزه ارضيه طالت شمال غرب
ايران الى مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه ما
يزيد عن 800 شخص بجروح وذكر مركزه رصد
الزلازل التابع لجامعه طيران ان الهزه
الارضيه ضربت مدينه اخوي في محافظه
اذربيجان قرب الحدود مع تركيا والتي بلغت
قوتها خمسه درجات فاصله تسعه وافقا وكاله
الانباء الايرانيه رسميه فانه وزير
الداخليه احمد وحيد توجه الى مدينه خويا
للاشراف على الوضع
مشاهدينا في نهايتها هذه الساعه الاخباريه
نذكر بابرد العناوين
الجيش الاوكراني يرفض تعزيزات روسيه
اضافيه الى البحر الاسود وتحركات قتاليه ل
15 سفينه
مسؤول ايراني يقر بفساد النظام ويصف
الاحتجاجات بالنار تحت الرماد ويرجح
الدلاعها من جديد
مقتل شاب برصاص مستوطن اسرائيلي في الضفه
واجراءات لحكومه نتنياهو ضد عائلات منفذ
الهجمات
نقي تونس يتلون باصواتهم في الدوري الثاني
بالانتخابات البرلمانيه وتدعوات للمقاطعه
في امان الله